se esperaba que casi 17 millones de
personas votarán hoy por el momento la
participación no ha sido comunicada por
la comisión electoral de ghana durante
todo el día los votantes fueron acogidos
en estricto cumplimiento de las cocinas
debida a la epidemia de coronavirus
llevarse más cara a lavarse las manos y
el distanciamiento social estaban a la
orden del día la votación de hoy será
claramente entre dos políticos nana
akufo addo y jon mamá que han estado
compartir el poder desde el 2012
la votación promete ser muy cerrada
aunque las encuestas dan dan a
akufo-addo como el gran ganador en
general las elecciones se desarrollan
sin problemas hay sólo un accidente
grave en el este del país en la ciudad
de caso a donde personas no
identificadas abrieron fuego contra el
coche de un ministro y la de la
oposición hirieron a cuatro personas
entre ellas un periodista